healing with the touch of a horse local
non-profit horses for heroes has made
that its mission and this weekend
they're hoping to spread awareness on
this very special type of therapy
victoria saha has the story
horses for heroes a non-profit ranch
helping our veterans cope with the
aftermath of combat i knew there was
something missing
but it wasn't anything that i could
describe jessica white is a navy veteran
and also a volunteer at the ranch it
took her 10 years to get back on a horse
after returning home it was freeing and
it made me just so happy that feeling of
euphoria is something white wants all
veterans to experience at a time where
they may feel nothing at all they
comfort you
and they will
bring you in like one of their own which
is why she's taking part in a three-day
certification course in equine assisted
learning held by greg kirsten they start
seeing
that they can do different things in
order to keep themselves safe kirsten a
veteran himself studies wild horses in
nevada he watched how they fend for
themselves and go through distress when
separated from their herd similar to
veterans transitioning from warrior life
to civilian life we still are working
with vietnam era veterans all the horses
here come from different backgrounds
just like our servicemen and women and
having that connection is so special for
equine therapy creating a strong bond
only the both of you can understand
everything you're thinking the horse
feels everything the horse
thinks you're feeling because it's just
you and that horse victoria saha live
local now